le hic on voit on voit la lumière au
fond on voit le cerveau d'un patient
c'est un peu comme un tunnel
peut-être des morts loïc tête est un peu
mort de l'intérieur
salut de la vidéo d'aujourd'hui on va
parler d une des expériences de mort
imminente aujourd'hui je m'intéresse au
sujet des expériences de mort imminente
avec un regard critique avec un regard
scientifique
même les témoignages que je vais
apporter dans la vidéo sont des
témoignages qui n'ont de valeur que nos
côtés témoignages les avis des
psychiatres qu'on arguments non la
valeur que l'avis du psychiatre qu'on a
recueilli voilà qu'est ce que c'est que
ce phénomène étrange qui se produit
après un violent accident de voiture un
arrêt cardiaque line operations et même
parfois un orgasme pourquoi certaines
personnes voient ce fameux tunnel avec
annie robes ou est-ce que c'est dû à des
substances libérées par le cerveau ou
est ce que c'est un phénomène unique il
explicable loïc génériques à
[Musique]
avant que la vidéo commence sachez quand
même qu'elle est sponsorisé par la
marque emma qui colle donc parfaitement
inutile de cette vidéo l'oeil parce que
lorsqu'on est allongée ce qu'on est dans
un état proche du sommeil je rêvais de
comprendre emma est une enseigne experte
en sommeil qui vendent des matelas des
milliers de nombreux accessoires la
marque est engagé dans le ghana de ses
clients et même de nombreuses recherches
jusqu'à moi afin de toujours sortir les
meilleurs produits pour nous permettre
tout simplement de mieux dormir car
intéressant c'est que l'on dort mieux
passer de meilleures journées on a une
meilleure mémoire des meilleures
compétences cognitives le sommeil est
d'ailleurs souvent négligée alors que
c'est lui qui va vous donner l'énergie
nécessaire à passer là la journée que
vous vouliez je suis bien placé pour
parler des bienfaits du sommeil je
pourrais d'ailleurs vous en parler des
heures mais c'est pas la thématique de
cette vidéo si vous voulez découvrir
leurs produits vous pouvez visiter leur
site grâce à ouvrir dans la description
qui va vous expliquer très bien les
bienfaits de leurs produits sur vos
nuits et par conséquent sur vos journées
et loïc et vous aussi si vous voulez
grâce à ce lien vous avez 10 % de
réduction supplémentaire rémy qui ont
déjà présentes sur le site
leur matelas hybride a d'ailleurs
remporté le prix qui s est que choisir
en 2021 et vous pouvez aussi utiliser
les codes fabien olicard tout attaché
pour bénéficier de ces bout portant
pendant six mois sur le site français et
sur le site belge de plus c'est sans
risque parce que la livraison et les
retours sont un tri sont gratuits vous
bénéficiez de s'ennuie décès et de dix
ans de garantie donc je vous le dis mon
bon monsieur m'abonne madan n'hésitez
plus faites un bon dodo alors je vous le
dis j'ai envie de faire une vidéo un
petit peu cheap on va parler
tranquillement on pourrait penser qu'il
est peu courant de vivre une expérience
de mort imminente ou une amie donc on
les appelle aussi comme ça et pourtant
d'après une étude qui a été présentée
lors du congrès de l'académie européenne
de neurologie à oslo puis les personnes
sur 10 auraient expérimenté c'est quand
même beaucoup et c'est pour ça que ça
m'a donné envie de faire cette vidéo
mais on va revenir avant sur ce que
c'est concrètement une aide imaginez
vous êtes chez vous tranquille hop une
petite crise cardiaque y ça arrive je
vous le souhaite pas mais ça peut
arriver vous perdez connaissance et là
vous sortez un peu de votre corps est
comme si vous flotter au dessus de vous
même vous ce qui se passe autour de vous
votre esprit conscient alors que votre
corps ne l'est pas vous vivez un
phénomène qu'on appelle là des
corporations site en existe évidemment
et là vous voyez une sorte de tunnel ou
minières très forte vous ressentez une
sensation apparemment de paix vous
percevez des êtres connues ou inconnues
et la boum vous revenez à vous vous êtes
dégoûtés vous avez mal partout ça en
gros et je résume évidemment celle
expérience de mort imminente comme on
peut souvent en entendre parler un truc
plutôt agréable et plutôt positif mais
il est aussi possible de vivre une
expérience effrayante voire
traumatisante et ça pour le coup c'est
plutôt rare qu'on en entende parler en
tout cas ça dépend vous l'aurez compris
c'est un phénomène qui se produit suite
à un événement physique grave ou des
fois d'ailleurs un état émotionnel
intense mais comment on peut être sûr
que la personne a vraiment vécu une
expérience de mort imminente de dire
qu'est ce qui nous prouve encore une
fois on n'a que sa parole en fête comme
preuve c'est jamais suffisant alors pour
ça il ya des gens qui ont essayé de
mettre des outils en place comme l'est
celle de résonance et un questionnaire
de 16 points qui va permet de vérifier
la fiabilité de ce témoignage on va y
retrouver des questions comme est ce que
le temps semble s accélérer ou ralentir
est-ce que vos sensations étaient plus
intense que d'habitude est-ce que vous
avez revu des scènes de votre passé ou
pas si la personne répond positivement à
cette question alors le amy est validé
donc c'est intéressant d'avoir un outil
un questionnaire parce que ça permet
cette validation mais après on peut
remettre en question aussi la viabilité
du questionnaire en lui-même c'est un
peu le serpent qui se mord la queue ce
que je vais vous dire par la suite va
peut-être vous étonner mais une telle
expérience ne survient pas forcément
qu'en cas de danger de mort mais aussi
lors de séances de méditation d'orgasme
de très fortes fièvres ou encore de
prise de drogue si on regarde les études
les expériences de mort imminente qui
ont été rapportés constitue un total de
100 % pour lequel les cas d'arrêt
cardiaque ne représentent que 25% c'est
assez faible en fait alors la grande
question c'est est ce qu'il s'agit d'un
phénomène naturel qui serait créée par
notre cerveau ou d'une expérience encore
plus sérieuse sur lequel on n'a pas de
données voire un truc un peu ésotérique
première théorie pour la plupart des
scientifiques il s'agirait d'un
mécanisme de défense et de survie en cas
de grave danger les chercheurs de
l'université de liège et de copenhague
également explique que ça ressemble
fortement aux mécanismes de défense des
animaux en cas de danger de mort on
appelle ça la thanatos les animaux y
mobilisent leurs corps mais complètement
pour simuler leur mort et pendant cet
instant on sait pas trop ce qu'ils
vivent mais c'est comme s'ils étaient
plus présents on n'est pas sûr que leur
pensée soit vraiment active est alors
selon steven laureys car neurologue à
l'université de liège l'acquisition du
langage aurait permis aux humains de
transformer ce comportement il de base
instinctif en phénomène sensorielle
riches qui s'étend même aux situations
sans prédation versant danger qui
laisserait supposer que notre
développement social permettrait à
chacun de vivre une expérience riche est
différente selon notre vécu nos
croyances etc en souci potel on pourrait
dire c'est parce que on pense qu'une
miss ça ressemble à ça qu'on vit ça
quand on fait une haie me voyez un petit
peu le passé encore le serpent sa
deuxième théorique de nombreuses autres
scientifiques suggèrent aussi que le
manque d'oxygène du cerveau pourrait
entraîner simplement cette expérience ce
qui pourrait causer en réalité des
hallucinations ni plus ni moins donc un
cerveau qui manque d'oxygène à libérer
de l'endorphine cette hormone elle peut
impacter le cortex visuel et le système
lundi ça ce sont des zones qui sont
reliés aux souvenirs même si les
souvenirs sont un peu partout qui pour
le coup difficilement explicable c'est
le phénomène de décorporation des
personnes qui sont capables de raconter
avec précision ce qui s'est passé
pendant une opération ce qui s'est dit
les objets qui étaient présents ou même
ce qui a pu se dérouler dans les lieux
annexes et c'est là tout le mystère donc
est ce qu'on peut vraiment parler
d'hallucinations pas forcément en même
temps on a aussi des contres témoignages
qui disent que par exemple la personne
qui était en des corporations et qui a
parlé d'une basket qui était sur la
rambarde l'autre côté de la fenêtre peut
être elle avait vu cette basket quand
elle est arrivée en fait dans l'immeuble
parce que si on refait son trajet on
voit qu'on la voyait est-ce que ça a été
stocké dans sa tête et romy dans
l'hallucination après en fait on est
obligé de tout envisager rien n'est
défini de ce côté là et pour continuer
si je vous disais qu'on pouvait créer
une expérience de mort imminente sur
commande si on vous proposait d'en vivre
une lame maintenant là tout de suite est
ce que vous vous auriez envie en tout
cas il y en a qui ont eu envie c'est ce
qu'ont fait les chercheurs de
l'université de columbia et à l'impérial
college de londres en administrant des
drogues à treize volontaires vous allez
voir c'est stupéfiant drogue stupéfiants
mais le mans les treize volontaires ont
accepté de se faire injecter de la
kétamine c'est un anesthésiant ainsi que
de la dîme et ils trippent tamines un
puissant psychotrope dmp beaucoup plus
simple à prononcer des 13 halls
enterrons le coup reçu leurs injections
et ont décrit tout ce qu'ils ont vécu
via un questionnaire concernant leur
ressenti et les résultats démontrent que
les volontaires soudaineté ont vécu une
expérience comparable à des sujets qui
ont vécu une vie sans drogue et ça ça
commence à intriguer les chercheurs
cependant petites différences dans les
zones naturelles on va dire la personne
a une sensation d'atteindre un point de
non retour qui peut s'expliquer par le
fait que pour les ennemis expérimental
et volontaire ou une préparation
psychologique et d'après les résultats
les treize volontaires qui avaient un
trait de personnalité de type absorption
étaient plus enclins à faire des ennemis
soudaineté pour info l'absorption c'est
la facilité avec laquelle une personne
s'extrait de son environnement extérieur
pour se concentrer sur sa vie intérieure
quand tu arrives à te mettre facilement
en introspection ils en disent quoi de
ça les chercheurs ils en font une
interprétation moins c'est leur métier
c'est que certains traits de
personnalité pourrait davantage
entraîner des expériences de mort
imminente de même pour ceux qui ont une
croyances au paranormal qu'ils ont
réussi à quantifier que plus on croyait
au paranormal et qu on croyait aux amis
qu on est enclin à en faire ce qui est
troublant dans les témoignages c'est
qu'il ya souvent eu un avant et un après
commande est simple à destination
aurait-elle le pouvoir de chambouler
autant une personne tout dépend en fait
de la porte est un peu mystique qu'on
met à cette hallucination si on pense
que cette hallucination n'en est pas une
évidemment elle va être impliquante et
encore une fois on ne sait pas si c'est
une hallucination pour toujours dans les
yeux et me positif certaines personnes
raconte n'avoir plus peur de la mort
depuis être plus sereine et avoir envie
de faire beaucoup de bien autour de soi
au contraire d'autres ont la pression
d'être prisonnière d'un corps lourd et
peuvent sombrer dans la dépression parce
qu'elles ont plus accès à cette
sensation qu'elles ont perçu de paix
intense complète ce truc qu'elles ont
vécu où tout était beaucoup plus simple
et plus léger d'ailleurs ça je
connaissais pas je découverte en
préparant cette vidéo est ce que vous
saviez qu'il existe aussi des
expériences de mort imminente partager
et ça ça remet en question toutes les
théories scientifiques puisqu'on parle
là d'une personne en bonne santé qui vit
une
avec une personne souffrante très très
bizarre le médecin raymond nous dit on a
parlé dans un livre qui s'appelle témoin
de la vie après il explique que des
personnes qui sont au chevet d'un
mourant peuvent vivre eux aussi la même
expérience une expérience de mort
imminente alors est ce qu'il existe une
mémoire partagée en dehors des corps
physique lui de son côté il explique que
cette hypothèse a été confirmée par des
chercheurs de l'université de harvard et
grâce à une expérience réalisée sur des
rats j'ai pas retrouvé cette expérience
donc je vous le dis comme l écrit dans
le livre des rats ont été amputé de la
moitié de leur cerveau et pourtant ils
se sont déplacés aussi rapidement dans
un labyrinthe que les autres rats qui
avaient leur cerveau intacte en gros
pour lui cela voudrait dire que la
mémoire serait peut être stockée dans un
autre endroit que le cerveau et ça
pourrait expliquer pourquoi des
personnes ont accès à des scènes de vie
d'un proche mourant alors qu'elle n'en
avait jamais eu connaissance auparavant
trouve ça intéressant d'en parler c'est
de l' hypothèse qui fait rêver qui fait
fantasmer mais qui n'a aucun fondement
et appui scientifique aujourd'hui encore
une fois je trouve que c'est une
interprétation un peu évidente est
facile de l'hypothèse parce qu'à ce
compte là on peut aussi expliquer sa
part un phénomène de télépathie dans ce
cas combien de fois ça nous est arrivé
avec une personne très proche de dire la
même phrase au même moment où de sentir
que la personne a un problème sans même
qu'elle nous en parle on peut pas
simuler sa de la télépathie on peut
aussi trouver des explications très
rationnel c'est à dire avoir
inconsciemment lui son langage non
verbal c'est quelque chose que je
connais bien et concernant le fait de
dire la même chose au même moment on
pourrait noter aussi toutes les fois on
ne dit pas la même chose au même moment
ils sont quand même plus nombreuses ça
veut dire qu'au final le mystère plane
toujours autour de ces expériences de
mort imminente les chercheurs avancent
des théories mais à ce jour on ne peut
pas affirmer avec certitude qu'il s'agit
d'un phénomène de survie ou un lien avec
le monde d'oxygénation du cerveau où
quelque chose de surnaturel ou quelque
chose de religieux ou quelque chose de
fantasmes et de supra normal de purement
ancré dans lequel on n'en sait rien tout
ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec
la méthode scientifique on n'est pas sûr
et certain que ça se passe vraiment
qu'on n'arrive pas à quantifier les
choses on a plutôt tendance à collecter
plein de données et de voir que
à peu près la même chose qui se raconte
à chaque fois malheureusement dans
l'hypothèse où on a tendance à avoir la
vision de ce qu'on a entendu dire au
départ aujourd'hui à l'heure de l' ultra
connectés on va tous avoir la même
sensation parce qu'on en a tous entendu
parler et cette vidéo party mais massa
donc est-ce que du coup les témoignages
qui vont dans ce sens prouveront que ça
existe ça va être une question très
compliquée ça peut être tout simplement
le cerveau qui nous fait un cadeau juste
avant de partir d'une espèce de
d'expériences positives à vivre j'en
sais rien j'en sais rien mais c'est pas
pour autant que j'avais pas envie d'en
parler ombre une fois sur la chaîne je
trouvais ça intéressant d'aborder le
thème des expériences de mort imminente
qui est quelque chose qui est partagée
par un grand nombre de personnes dans
l'humanité donc ça valait le coup d'en
parler j'espère que ça vous a plu merci
d'ailleurs aussi à emma devra bien voulu
sponsorisé cette vidéo n'oubliez pas que
toutes les infos et le code de réduction
sont dans la description si vous voulez
un meilleur sommeil aller chez eux et
vous dites moi en commentaires si vous
avez déjà des cuissards une amy ici
quelqu'un de vous de votre entourage
vous en arts a raconté ligne ce serait
un petit peu ce qui fait dire ça dans
les commentaires si vous ne connaissez
pas je m'appelle toujours fabien olicard
ces mêmes marques et sur mon affiche ça
c'est la tige de mon spectacle en
création qui tourne dans toute la france
qui doit rester dix représentations il
reste des places alors c'est à côté de
grandes villes bien si vous reconnaissez
pas regardé un peu le chiffre de la
région et du département et puis bah
passer me voir quand qui reste des
places un très très plaisir le bien est
aussi dans la description ça s'arrête en
juin après sa bosse pour le nouveau
spectacle ici je vous mets une vidéo où
ciba qui répond à toutes les questions
de luminaires en fait 42 toi même tu
sais et là je mets une autre vidéo sur
un un gros christelle les castels des
fois qu'ils sont trop dures ces maisons
et mis un mois donc regarder le ciel est
très chouette tu prends soin de toi loïc
ou pas oui va alors prenez soin de loïc
et prenez aussi soin de vous à très
bientôt shao la lumière la lumière
[Musique]